but when your pants get stuck to the
back of your leg
[Applause]
when your hair is out of control
when the boob sweat leaves a stain on
your shirt
[Music]
there is sweat coming from my butthole
really hate
the
humidity
[Music]
baby my
bones are extra long
and
sweaty
oh i swear
sweat comes out of places you didn't
know you had
and women adjust themselves as much as
men
[Music]
the only difference is when they pick a
from
wedgie
women pull it out with both hands
baby now
[Music]
how come i sweat when i'm in the shower
i mean how is that even possible
i just used 14 towels
yeah i
swear to lie
well he is so thick i'm breathing
applesauce
there you go